this took a dark turn but it's not
necessarily even the dark you i'm
talking about
on some yeah like you out in the street
[ __ ] but just the same when you going to
talk to these [ __ ] agents and
and managers and [ __ ] they can promise
you the world they don't rob you with
guns they rob you with the words and the
papers and [ __ ]
that's some jada kiss by the way they do
that
it's not everybody is a [ __ ] shark
bro some [ __ ] get you with the
knife some get you with the pen bruh
ooh ooh
you got got like on the on the pin yeah
everybody has but that's part of the
game though
knowing knowing your work if you you
don't never know what these people
made off of this [ __ ] you just know what
you agreed to right
right what can i just to keep it maybe
towards comedians more because that's
the world we're in
it's like what are what are some maybe
red flags we can keep an eye out for
from mistakes or lessons you've had to
learn the red flags
just don't be out here trusting people
don't be believing this [ __ ] man
don't if it sounds good too good to be
true it is man
you know what i mean nobody is out here
looking for your best interest and don't
nobody give a [ __ ] about your feelings
sooner you learn that [ __ ] the more you
can the better you can understand it
the person you ride your homie might be
your dog
you might anything bro but don't never
think that
somebody's gonna do something for you
just because they [ __ ] with you
nobody it's all it's all a business man
and you can see you start to see it once
you get start working it like
business they don't give a [ __ ] about
who you think is funny or whatever they
gonna
put whoever on this show because that's
what they doing it's their club
they hired you but they had these other
[ __ ] too oh what other business
advice could you share
um like i said invest in yourself
and find and find another way find more
than one way to get paid
don't just think don't just get paid off
telling jokes
because people steal jokes all the time
and and the people not gonna check to
see who wrote it they don't give a [ __ ]
they just know who excuse me they just
laughed at it because
and that's what was available at the
time thank you [ __ ] who it came from
or how old this joke is none of that
just get your money and don't never
worry about what somebody else doing you
might get you might get hired and
be doing the exact same [ __ ] and these
[ __ ] standing right beside you
got five got paid five times more than
you just because they asked for it and
you didn't
because they had the right
infrastructure set up they handled
business they had the right manager the
right agent
and they got what they asked for so that
plays a big part into it your team
right yeah you you gotta like you can't
be successful by yourself man
i see you just now you're saying you got
to look out for yourself but then you
can't be successful
by yourself nobody gets successful by
themselves huh don't never believe that
nobody you start [ __ ] around
and paying attention to how people get
into the industry
the the industry industry is always
somebody else
who got them in there somebody uncle was
a producer
or their dad was a wrote a motown song
you know i'm saying you never know the
connections you your name will get you a
whole lot further than your talent will
your reputation precedes you being funny
is just
that's just one of the 10 things you got
to do to get
just to be in the conversation and you
can't you can't just be fly by night
funny
you got to be consistently funny it's
people who are at the top of the game
who want to [ __ ] with you
but they just want to see how you handle
the next three years or
see how you develop and what kind of
sense you have in the next year so where
you at can you stay in there
a lot of people come and go can you stay
hot
like getting hot is easy because don't
nobody know you you
just you do magic every night like where
did he come from right
and then you get in that position where
it's like now you're expected to create
magic
are you really a magician
it's a great analogy yeah it's the facts
though man
it's the back
like [ __ ] want to be in that
spot but then when you get in that spot
you got to do that hour and a half after
everybody in the club just came and did
their best [ __ ]
can you do it are you made of that
really made up man it's the third show
of the night you can you do three at
night
that's what headliners do can you come
on stage and say [ __ ] it i'm out here
where you where your improv
[ __ ] at are you off the cuff or you can
only tell jokes that you wrote
you might be a headliner but you might
what if you only got exactly one hour of
jokes to tell
yeah word for word
how do you freestyle i like
what is what is the technique behind it
because i'll try sometimes but then
if one thing misses i may start to doubt
and then i'll start to
work backwards but i've seen potential
in it but i i
you know i end up tucking my tail and
running you can't do that bro when you
telling jokes you don't wait for this
crowd to approve this [ __ ]
it's funny you tell the joke like you
tell that [ __ ]
with the same conviction as you tell
your joke that you know is a banger
because it's not the joke best one it's
you you got to be a funny person
that's why i always wonder how some
people made it
to you know this long because they're
not funny people they're not
funny at school they're not funny at
work they weren't funny growing up
they never make nobody they never made
me laugh and all these years i've known
them like what is it that you are doing
how are you sustaining you get what i'm
saying
yeah yeah yeah who is booking this
[ __ ] how do they have a demand
maybe they have a good team exactly you
could
some people do so it's how you say your
joke
it's because you can get a lot caught up
in that writing that's what i'm saying
bro you have to detach yourself from
i'm a comedian here's a joke that's so
cookie-cutter it's not
being a comedian it's not the joke
comedians make [ __ ] funny the [ __ ] don't
you know what i mean you don't
and making something funny doesn't mean
going on stage a bunch of times and
saying that [ __ ] and trying to figure
out to make it funny
like a comedian is the type of person
who can be
going into an audition and might say to
say one word
one word wrong 50 times but it's funny
every time they [ __ ] up
that's the comedian now a comic can sit
at home all day and
write jokes and flip channels and do
little interpretations of what this
comedian said a little word flip here
and there
but that's all prepared [ __ ] they do
their impression of a comedian they put
all black on and
little goofy ass hat and want to tell
jokes with a
where might stand in a stool because
that's what they're
the essence of comedy but they're not
funny people
you know what i'm saying some people
just don't have that natural spark
they can deliver a joke or they can say
some [ __ ] somebody wrote for them but
they're not
funny people so it's different skill
sets
so maybe somebody may be a better joke
writer and not as good improviser
right that's just like saying
you just i'll use instruments all the
time it's just like saying you're a dope
ass trumpet player
but you can only play a song if you got
the music
you don't really know how to play that
[ __ ]
you don't really know how to play that
[ __ ] like
if you you know what i'm saying you see
people play basketball
some [ __ ] are great basketball
players and they're good like any other
any other court you put them on they are
[ __ ] amazing
but then you put them on a court with
lebron and [ __ ] steph curry and k.d
and
they look like children you know what
i'm saying they're not built for that
they bought it really physically not
built for that bro
he's like you just not made for this
[ __ ] you're the best point guard in the
league but you can never be a [ __ ]
small forward you'll never be a sinner
but then it's some [ __ ] who you
could put them on the court and you
don't even have to tell them what to do
some some people just naturally gifted
bo jackson's
deion sanders the [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying the talent just [ __ ]
proceed the odell beckham's they can do
any [ __ ] thing bruh
and they just ain't good at it if
they're not good at it they're at least
good enough at it to captivate you and
make you watch them not be good at it
so you got to have self belief too man
that's got to play into it that
confidence seems the longer i've been
doing comedy you know i've been doing it
over eight years now
and it seems like confidence can really
drive the audience response
yeah man if you can make people like you
it doesn't matter what you say because
they like you
they want you that when people like you
they treat you different
because you give them something you give
them a feeling
it's happiness if you can make people
happy [ __ ] what you do [ __ ] the jokes
that you told
they'll come see you a hundred times
cause you make them happy
it's an atmosphere you acknowledge them
you talk to people different
that's the part about that's the part
when you can find out what makes people
like you that's what'll make you a star
that's why kevin hart is winning so hard
right now he found out how to make
people like him
he's a likable you want to see him win
you celebrate his victories with him
because he make you feel like you're a
part of
so find out what people like about you
right it might not necessarily be the
jokes
it might be your stupid aunt's pants or
your little
boyish grin or your voice they just
might like you because you're a tall
[ __ ]
or they might like you because you're a
pretty fat [ __ ] you're just a
fly person you smell good you carry
yourself different you got a different
swag your delivery
you gotta accent from where you from it
all go back to you though
right what type you gotta find like this
is my best advice
find a highlighter and use it on
yourself
like if you're a woman with some big ass
titties let people know you know you got
them [ __ ] so you got big brown eyes
whatever the [ __ ] all of these are your
weapons if you can sing if you can
do an impression you can sound just like
a [ __ ] these are all talents you
bring to the stage because
they only get that [ __ ] from you boom
and you have a lot of different talents
man how are you planning on
using these going forward hey hot
brother and sister
if you love comedy as much as we do here
at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch
more videos to get even more comedy tips